your issues with with just mental health
which i think you were kind of one of
the first players that kind of embraced
like
uh facing that uh
when you saw the ben simmons thing
playing out recently obviously he just
got traded to the nets it looks like
he's gonna be playing soon um did you
kind of
have any sort of like did you kind of
relate to what he could be going through
or did you like how did you kind of feel
about the ben simmons thing um
well he's not the first player to go
through something
since i retired or even as since i've
been thinking about
like what players go through
that's one of the reasons i started come
out but
um that situation was really unique
because
like i wanted him to play
for sure i personally wanted to see him
play
um
[Music]
so
but then i also understand i wanted to
retire when i was 23.
so i kind of understand a little bit
on not wanting to play or something
getting in the way
like nothing should ever get in the way
of you playing i think it's a way to hit
like if you want to get traded i think
it's a way to handle it
you know um because i handle it the
wrong way so i'm thinking about it you
you took those those wounds for him kind
of like yo i i like you like you said
you you you handled at certain point in
times in your career you handled things
the wrong way yeah there's a way to
handle [ __ ] right yeah i think i think
for every circumstance an mba is a way
to handle it like for example if you
don't want to be on the team
you can
talk to your agent talk to the owner
general manager and be like listen
i don't want to be here
um i don't want to make a big deal out
of it
so i'm a play but let's really
move me but what then what happens is
what if the fans start loving you all
right what are you playing well and the
fans start loving you right and you're
now the general manager gonna look crazy
by trading right here right cause y'all
don't have no issues but like how do you
really handle it or maybe you can say
hey i don't want to be here
but still play the game still be a
professional i guess right i mean
i couldn't tell someone to be
professional because i wasn't
professional so i don't like to really
say things that i wasn't
yeah you had some pretty unprofessional
moments you know what i'm saying yeah
you know i don't i don't ever like to
call nobody like be professional
but i can say be professional but i i
wouldn't want to say like
um you know you're not professional and
just leave it there i would like to like
explain why i think like you should be
more professional or why i would benefit
you know what i'm saying versus like
criticizing yeah you've been through it
yeah i've done it yeah yeah um did you
ever request it formally a trade while
you were in the league um i didn't
actively try to get about it somewhere
like unprofessionally unprofessionally
yeah
was that in indiana um
in chicago i pretty much
forced that one
indiana
i was very unprofessional by coming out
in the media and saying i want to be
traded
sacramento no
just those two teams did you win because
actually the knicks was uh linux also
the next i forgot you played for the
next i played with nixon into my career
i didn't request the trade but i was
like kind of upset and